cause a BBC spokesman spokesperson has
said this stay with us Matthew yeah the
BBC has been an extensive discussions
with Gary and his team in recent days we
have said that we consider his recent
social media activity to be a breach of
our guidelines the BBC has decided that
he will step back from presenting match
of the day until we've got an agreed and
clear position on his use of social
media when it comes to Leading our
football and sports coverage Gary is
second to none we have never said that
Gary should be an opinion-free zone or
that he can't have a view on issues that
matter to him but we have said that he
should keep well away from taking sides
on party political issues or political
controversies so Matthew given that
um just outline again what it is all
this is about is about him having an
opinion on social media isn't it exactly
I mean that was with exquisite timing
spoke to exactly what I was in the
middle of saying which is that this idea
of Jew impartiality means that they
don't expect the same from Gary Lee
occur as they do from say you know Nick
Robinson on The Today program political
and news people who deal in politics
every day have a higher standard of
impartiality of Jew impartiality that
applies to them Gary lineker is employed
largely for his expertise in football
rather than politics so it's less
significant but nonetheless though
clearly is a a line the BBC feels that
he's crossed that line I'm quite
interested though by that statement in
the sense that it doesn't appear that
his uh contract with match today is
necessarily being severed completely
forgive me I don't have the statement
right in front of me but it almost
signed it as though this was a
suspension or a temporary pause he was
stepping back whilst they agreed what
the policy would be going forward and
that Gary lineker perhaps accepted some
stricter controls on what he says on
social media in order to continue
presenting match of the day so that's an
interesting possibility the BBC also has
social media guidelines for its staff
and that's also another thing that the
BBC will have considered in terms of
whether or not Gary lineker breached it
in his uh
tweet the other day about just to remind
me what it actually was as he said he
compared some of the rhetoric and
wording that's being used by the
government over the small boats and
migrant crisis to similar to what was
being used by Germany in the 1930s he
said clearly the BBC feels that even by
those standards of due impartiality that
I outlined a moment ago he's gone too
far they're going to perhaps recalibrate
his relationship perhaps set out some
clearer standards by which he feels he's
able to tweet things again bearing in
mind that he is employed to talk about
football and so he perhaps has a bit
more leeway to express his opinions on
things than as I said Nick Robinson or
any of the other BBC's major Hugh
Edwards or something like that would
would do but clearly there is a line at
which the BBC feels they have to put
their foot down they've done so and it
doesn't sound like he's completely being
sacked or or resigning from his role at
match of the day but clearly there's
some work now that needs to go on to
determine delineate if you like exactly
where that line is so Gary feels like
he's able to say things he wants to say
but without perhaps dragging the BBC
into the kind of political raw and
slanging match that has been over the
last week or so